I was like oh shoot you know I'm gonna
do this video so I try to do like some
eight-minute abs and I did it again this
morning feel like I should have been
working out for the past like six months
a lot of people see me and they think
that oh he's a sin guy he's not insecure
the way he looks but I think everyone is
insecure I struggle with a lot of body
confidence issues
I'm not incredibly proud of my body I
think I haven't okay about it going into
this I am hoping to gain a new
perspective on clothing and style coming
into this very just like more on the
uncomfortable end and hoping that I
break out of that show and just own this
crop top I want to showcase my body and
not be ashamed of it
oh my god it's like wearing a toothpick
no matter it hey Maggie
oh my god at the beginning of the day I
was so so uncomfortable
Peter blocks of you I was prepared to
see that I've just never seen you in
this way and your boxers above your
jeans is making me laugh because it's
like the boy version of a whale tail
girl is like the thong stick pretty
watch okay literally pull this down from
I thought you just like had your shirt
but you look great
appreciate a girl wearing a crop top for
a day it was really uncomfortable for me
I feel self-conscious same Oh a lot of
flexing we just got our lunch and we
were waiting for probably good like 5 or
10 minutes and it just really felt
awkward the whole time I'm an introvert
so I don't like being like the person
that everybody's staring at so
apparently I've been wearing crop tops
wrong I got advice from one of the top
knot girls you're supposed to wear
high-waisted pants or have something
tied around you right Crystal's teaching
me the proper way to sit when I write a
crop top
you got a perch on the end really flat
so it's the middle of the day and I just
went to the canteen and there were like
some co-workers there none of them said
anything so I guess it might be more
acceptable to wear this that I really
think it is and then as you go
throughout the day it's kind of like
well you know whatever like everybody's
staring so might as well give them
something to look at right so as the day
is progressing I'm getting much more
confident this is like one of the
hottest days we've had in a while so I
feeling less awkward thank you
when you crept up definitely made me
more insecure about my own body I think
we all are our own worst critic I still
got a lot of like weird looks like why's
that guys like belly all up everywhere
that being said this article of clothing
was the most comfortable thing I've worn
in a very long time by the end of the
day I had accepted myself and I didn't
didn't matter what people are saying
because I felt secure in my body down
one I think I wouldn't mind trying it
out again but probably not anytime soon